the revolution will be televised on
Sunday President Trump launched a new
news of the week segment on his Facebook
page to tout the achievements of his
administration left-wing propagandists
at network news outlets who shill for
Democrats nightly and broadcast across
public airwaves have disparaged
president Trump's Facebook post as
propaganda and state TV will discuss
plus campus carry activist Antonia
Okafor roaming millennial and for some
reason Jacob Airy will join the panel of
deplorable z-- to talk pence 20/20 the
surge and black female gun ownership and
how to tell it your child is transgender
on Michael Nolt and this is the Michael
nose
[Music]
Frenchman Trump has launched what is now
being called Trump TV it's a weekly
segment to talk about his administration
and give the the real news on his
Facebook page and CNN contributor
Kayleigh mcenany was the one who
launched this last night let's take a
look at the debut episode compostable
uranium is our Hong Kong see you on TV
when were totally sanguine
oh yes in Paris I can guess all women
okay - una hummert one young fan follow
you give me four episode of Hong Kong
heading it up you know Kaylee has a
really thick accent I didn't remember
that on her incredible you know that is
that would I guess we got our feeds
mixed up that is North Korean government
propaganda but that is what Evan
McMullen is comparing it to for those of
you who don't remember Evan McMullen
which should be everybody
he was the spoiler candidate he was the
so-called conservative who ran to throw
the election for Hillary Clinton he was
an old house Republican aide and a CIA
officer and he tweeted quote this is the
type of propaganda you'd see in North
Korea it erodes the people's ability to
discern truth and hold government
accountable you know with Republicans
like Evan McMullen who needs Democrats
he has spent every moment since Donald
Trump was elected president trying to
tear this guy down every day is more
hyperbolic than the next the notion that
President Trump puts out a new messaging
platform on his Facebook page is now
rises to the heights of North Korean
state propaganda Evan McMullen brought
up propaganda that's fine let's let's
look at some propaganda do we have a cut
of it yes as we provide you the news of
the week from Trump Tower here in New
York more great economic news on Friday
the July jobs report added a better than
expected 209 thousand jobs overall since
the president took office President
Trump has created more than 1 million
jobs
the unemployment rate is at a 16 year
low and consumer confidence is at a 16
year high all while the Dow Jones
continues to break records President
Trump has clearly steered the economy
back in the right direction on Wednesday
the president introduced the raise
average for decades a steady rise in
immigration has depressed the wages of
American workers the raise act will
increase wage increase poverty and save
the taxpayers billions Americans deserve
a raise and President Trump is finally
putting the American worker first thank
you for joining us everybody I'm Kaylee
McInerney and that is the real news it's
on American watch out the secret police
are going to be coming soon this this is
what Evan McMullen is afraid of the
terrible news state TV and propaganda
and it is I I am half joking it is
obviously propaganda but what is
propaganda propaganda is messaging in
the use of information to advance a
political goal or a political campaign
every political campaign uses that every
politician uses it that's why they have
directors of communication that's why
they have political directors because
they want to dictate the news cycle get
their message out there and cut through
their opponents who are all around them
when it comes to President Trump he has
the entire deck stacked against him so
you know if that is propaganda
and by the way propaganda is not a bad
thing
I think it's spoken of as some some
awful and unamerican activity propaganda
when there's a lot on both sides is
evidence of a healthy political system
now Democrats want to limit political
speech they want to restrict the right
of people to air commercials and hold
rallies and spend money advancing
political speech but Republicans say
that's fine you have a microphone for
your message we'll have a microphone for
our message we don't care if MSNBC is
out there we're in at Fox News refuting
some of those some of the issues that
are coming out of left wing news outlets
if that is propaganda and I suppose it
is let's look at other propaganda that
might help the other side only times
them he can be funny this is one of the
brightest presidents one of the most of
debt that we've had perhaps in our
lifetime
Brod he has a great image for America
Barack Obama the rising rock star
it's about Barack Obama the rock star is
rock star popularity he still informed
he circumspect he's articulate he's
awful
I miss him so much so he's so perfect
this is he is dr. Isaac it now by the
way this wasn't on some Facebook page
this wasn't the president posting a
little video of an articulate and cute
blonde lady to his own Facebook page
this is the entire mainstream media so
if we're worried about state TV this is
actual state TV and and by the way I
think a lot of Millennials don't know
this but there are airwaves not
everything is Hulu Netflix and cable
there are these airwaves that are
regulated by the government and these
people on ABC NBC CBS are broadcasting
in public airwaves they're shilling for
Democrats every night they're attacking
Republicans and especially this
president every night and I don't
begrudge them that I think that's just
fine in in the American Republic but
then to fly in defensive hysterics
because President Trump decides to send
his message out on his own Facebook page
seems a little ridiculous let's look at
some more propaganda from those same
public airwaves networks if Trump wins
how about bursting into tears and
screaming [ __ ] for the next 45 minutes
so America is crying tonight I'm not
sure how much of America but a very very
significant portion and I mean literally
crying everybody is crying and so upset
and it is the end of their world feels
like the end of the world on a lifetime
left right and I was slowly getting
drunk and what happened how do we
explain how this is possible how did
this happen experienced politician
versus racist fake gynecologist get your
abortions now because we're going to be
[ __ ] and we're going to have to live
with it you're awake by the way you're
not having a terrible terrible dream
also you're not dead and you haven't
gone to hell this is your life now this
is our election now this is us this is
our country this is a different earth
today than it was 24 hours ago it's a
different place of cause it just is
different the woman who President Obama
called the most qualified person ever to
run for the White House could have
breakthrough the question remains who
can deeper concerns tonight that the
world's shining light of democracy has
gone dark you see that's not propaganda
that's just the credible news coverage
of those objective journalists who are
under siege but president Trump sending
a spokesman out and set touting his
achievements of the past week or two
weeks that is the threat to our
democracy by the way Marshall great job
bleeping all the swear words on there we
should have used sip recruiter I guess
but maybe next time this this is also
nothing new both sides are not new the
left-wing media complex shilling for
Democrats and flying into fits of
hysterics that's obviously not new
that's been going on for decades but
also releasing addresses on social media
platforms are on your own outlets
there's nothing new about that either
here's President Trump giving a similar
address himself my fellow Americans as
we celebrate American Dream week at the
White House we continue to see
incredible results this week the Dow
Jones Industrial Average reached an
all-time high never ever has it been so
high that must be all of those sensors
trying to cut out our president Trump
clip I think you get the picture he's
out there in a typical Trump subtlety
you know just going right down the list
of all of the achievements that he's
ascribing to his political leadership
and that's just fine successful
presidents do this FDR had his famous
fireside chats he would give of a gave
about 30 radio addresses during his
presidency to communicate directly the
American people from the Library of
Congress they said of those they were an
influential series of radio broadcasts
in which Roosevelt utilized the media to
present his programs and ideas directly
to the public and quote thereby
redefined the relationship between
President Roosevelt and the American
people in 1933 nothing wrong about it
politicians and presidents always use
media and that was a first major use of
mass media the JFK knew that he was
excellent at TV there is I think
something of a an apocryphal story that
when he debated President Nixon in 1960
the radio listeners thought Nixon won
and the TV listeners thought JFK why
there's there's not a lot of evidence to
support that directly but I think
everybody agreed that JFK's excellent
performance on TV was one of the reasons
that he won that election and also those
dead bodies in Ohio probably gave it to
him too but it was one of the reasons
why he he had a successful campaign and
it certainly helped him throughout his
presidency Ronald Reagan use radio and
TV regularly he would broadcast to the
nation and from 1975 to 1979 I think
people forget this he had a five minute
radio daily show where he would address
different issues and prepare his own
campaign Barack Obama was so good at
using social media he would appear on
all of these different Internet
platforms that awful Zach Galifianakis
between two ferns show you that he
actually had a strategist working on his
jib strategy those little moving images
he had somebody on his team working on
how to make the most put him in gifs in
the best possible light so there's
there's nothing new about this and
unfortunately for the right GOP
candidates have generally refused to do
this we've been behind the ball dealing
with the media probably since Ronald
Reagan famously in 2012 Mitt Romney was
debating Barack Obama and on a point
there was a point of contention the
moderator Candy Crowley entered herself
into the debate lied right through her
teeth lied on behalf of Barack Obama
Mitt Romney was unable to refute that he
didn't punch back same with John McCain
John McCain famously suspended his own
presidential campaign to virtue signal
during the financial crisis at that
point I think we all knew that Barack
Obama had it even if we thought he might
have had it before that and President
Bush George W Bush famously refused to
dignify the media attacks you saw some
of them they are against President Trump
they were just as bad against george w
bush he felt it would be below the
dignity of the president to fight back
against them clearly that hampered much
of the progress that could have been
made during his administration it ruined
his reputation throughout the country
and it hurt Republicans politically the
idea here is that campaigns are never
really over Barack Obama knew this very
well he kept his campaign apparatus
Obama for America he renamed it
organizing for America he had the
campaign running during his entire
presidency it's still running now
man it hasn't been president in a while
and nevertheless his campaign apparatus
is still going strong which is why
politicians have political directors so
president Trump is using a campaign
tactic here that seems just fine you
know some are saying this is more
nefarious but I think here's some more
evidence to the contrary just a few
hours ago Kaley mcenamey was named the
RNC spokesman she's the new spokesman
for the Republican National Committee
this is a new way that they're going to
get their message out seems just fine
she said quote while I've enjoyed my
time at CNN I will be moving to a new
role stay tuned next week she got in a
few jabs about CNN being fake news and
she's moving to real news as you heard
in the clip I'd also like to remind all
of us that it was the left who started
using that term fake news we
appropriated it from them
obviously to great effect and we're
having a lot of cathay fun with it
mainstream media hysteria is probably a
good barometer of the effectiveness of
Republican strategies the angrier they
get the more we're punching them where
it hurts unlike some of our recent
Republican leaders here is president
Trump's thought on how to fight the
media but with me we fight back I like
it let's fight back with that let's
bring on our panel of deplorable z-- I
don't know how I got so lucky but today
we have a truly excellent panel of
deplorable z-- we have Antonio Okafor
well-known campus carry activists at
Second Amendment activists we have again
somehow we've got roaming millennial
coming to us at like 3:00 in the morning
from wherever she is and then because
we're a charity here we're very generous
we brought on the always funny and
articulate Jacob arey from conservative
news Antonia will this strategy help
Trump reach out to people he otherwise
wouldn't reach or is he just preaching
to the choir no absolutely I think it
definitely is going through just like
Twitter I mean people will still go
upset hey you need to you know shut down
your account but I mean I listen I look
at it every day to see what some real
real news is versus the fake news so I
think it's this going to help his cause
and it's going to help him in in 2020 so
more power to them that's a coin when
you go on to get news now you
to go to different websites I still go
to some news website but when I want
breaking news I go straight to Twitter
that seems to be the place where the
news actually manages to break through
well I try go ahead are you sorry I'm
gonna say I work I they are and
literally would be like oh you just
tweeted that a car not get it out so I
think that's what most are doing right
now is dictating the news cycle which is
something we haven't done in far too
long
roaming this might not be dangerous
propaganda or state TV but is it a
little unseemly
to put this cute bubbly articulate
blonde on Facebook and have her tout
your politics or is that just just good
politics well I mean I think if anything
we can all agree that the production
values are somewhat tacky I thought that
was the actor there very classy what are
you talking about but now I don't I
don't see how you can look at this what
Facebook video post and say that it's
nefarious to the equivalent to state-run
propaganda which by the way I mean BBC
and CBC in Britain and Canada that's
actual legitimate state-run media you
know this this is this is a Facebook
post right I mean this is it's not like
they're commandeering the airwaves and
broadcasting this you know to
televisions across across the nation
this is totally different and I think
you know what what like with Trump
Twitter feed yeah there there are people
who would just be following it to agree
with everything who wouldn't be
conferenced to the Trump administration
but there are people who are going to be
like kind of curious like hey this seems
kind of crazy maybe I'll watch it just
to laugh at him maybe I want to see how
ridiculous it is and dentil end up
hearing things that they wouldn't have
otherwise so worth it either way in my
opinion an excellent show many is a good
communicator and I follow it for the CAF
FA Jacob it's a tell me Jake if it seems
to me conservatives and Republicans they
don't want to associate that closely
with him because he's uncouth he seems a
little classless he as as a roaming
pointed out the production value could
probably use a little work but they seem
more concerned with disappearance than
with achieving results is that fair or
am I too harsh on them no I actually
agree with you and you know you know me
I'm not a huge Trump supporter but I
actually think this is a this is a good
idea I think that
it helps President Trump get his message
out I you know and like you said that
the media hysteria determines its
success right wall post headline was
real news more like real propaganda it
sounded like a teenage girl tweeting out
something and then the mirror Donald
Trump quietly launches his own
propaganda he didn't quietly launch
anything it was he put it out there
right on his Facebook and I just I think
that conservatives need to get on board
with this and we need to see more of it
from conservative lawmakers great on
state-regulated TV you have wall-to-wall
anti Trump he makes a Facebook post and
all of a sudden he's a tin-pot dictator
that's great okay I know you want to
hear more we have these great guests in
studio today you want to hear from them
you want to see them but you can't if
you're too cheap what you need to do is
go over to Daley wire calm subscribe for
just ten dollars a month a hundred
dollars a year you get everything you
get the leftist here's tumblr which
keeps your leftist ears hot or cold
always salty you get access to the great
panel of deplorable z-- my show Ben
Shapiro's show Andrew Clayton's show
this Thursday we're going to have flex
talks in studio or first in studio
guests you'll get to see that interview
but only if you subscribe so get off
these free channels and go give us your
money daily wire calm we'll be right
back
all right on Saturday the New York Times
which is that former newspaper the
answer Flavin's always talking about
reported that Mike Pence is seeking to
challenge President Trump for the White
House in 2020 with the headline
Republican shadow campaign for 2020
takes shape as Trump doubts grow I don't
know who told them that somebody told
them that there are reports that Kasich
Pence Ben Sasse are eyeing the throne
Bill Kristol is finally going to get
this one out of here and form a
committee not to renate the president
Pence has vigorously denied the rumors
the New York Times has fake news I'm not
surprised roaming is pence going to run
and if he does
would he have a chance or is this just
New York Times wishful thinking well I
don't think he's going to run you know
that obviously looks awful for the Trump
administration you're you're sitting
vice president running against the
sitting president in the primaries
that's not that's not going to happen I
don't think as destructive as the you
know RNC is that look could ever allow
that but you know tears of whether she
would actually win if he hypothetically
does run I'm a huge pants fan I think
he's great he's you know constitutional
conservative pro by pro-second amendment
great guy in my book however um the
people who are triggered by Trump they
would go apocalyptic if it were actually
pence right I think pence being VP is
actually Donald Trump anti assassination
protection about that you know it'll s
just were to target him
guess who's president next it's heads
right if you want to talk about look at
light wing guy in the country right so
as much as I like him I don't think
you'd actually have a chance of winning
over people like independents who voted
for Trump over Hillary in 2016 I just
don't see it happening
sounds like sour grapes is that Antonia
is that it is this just sour grapes by
the anti-trump crowd or is there is
there some good argument on the right to
kick out Trump make him a one-term
president well first I feel like I need
to address the else in the room I am at
a gun range and if you guys are hearing
gunshots it's because of that I love I
love it the Michael nul show a panel we
have gunshots literally being fired in
the background also Antonia that makes
you I think the coolest person I've ever
met
sorry go on what
well that makes them but yeah definitely
with the Trump thing I just think come
on disagree and in subside of New York
Times it was like as if like wash PO and
you know the hill and everybody was like
you guys and you let's just make sure
New York Times like puts it in first so
people actually think there's
credibility to the actual story I think
more and more people especially because
of trouble administration are starting
to see legitimize these type of you know
news organizations that put out stuff
that are really just like really come on
I think most people know that there's a
shadows campaign or rather that they're
just buying for their own seat later on
it has nothing to do was trying to take
Trump out I mean even the candidates are
trying to go against oh sorry guys after
the lights went out on Antonia I knew
you'd be secure the best shot known yet
so even with those you know that it's
not going to be an issue oh so yeah
chorus politicians are always looking
after their own political interests are
always checking out possibilities but
you know right now we've got Bill
Kristol John Kasich been set they all
seem determined to dethrone President
Trump
Jacob is it time for never Trump to give
it a rest you know and support the
nominee of their party not only nominee
their party the guy that they're
partying the rest of the country made
president have we had enough of never
Trump I actually am an unique position
here cuz I actually was never Trump if
you read on my blog
it's full of never Trump propaganda
honestly though yes it's time to move on
we try never Trump he got elected it's
time to back him when he does
conservative things and call him out
when he does left-wing things that's
what we need to do and I honestly don't
think people like Ben Sasse maybe John
Kasich but I don't think like senator
Ben Sasse I don't think he's going to
risk his political capital to run for
the presidency I mean that would
virtually in his Senate career I think
but someone might see someone like a
John Kasich or you know someone war on
the outside a form a former governor
a former senator and maybe a house house
representatives congressman or
congresswoman but I don't think we're
going to see anyone substantial really
mount a challenge against Trump so we
were through with John Kasich oh here he
comes back but I mean I think if there's
one good thing we can say about this
whole current nevertron movement is that
john Kasich's involvement is probably
the best significant right i so we can
take comfort in that love is a clear
energy is political strategy of running
as a republican and just criticizing
every republican that ever lives that
that's how we're going to win their
hearts and minds well we're very lucky
now we actually have an expert on our
next subject 59% of african-american
households now view owning a gun as a
necessity according to Pew Research
Jacob I know you identify as a black
woman but that we're gonna have to talk
about that later on in the transgender
discussion Antonia you are the expert
why the surge and why now
I don't know I'm according to like all
the other black liberals apparently I'm
not really black and also not woman
because I'm pro-life
I don't repeat yeah but since today I'll
humor you I meant black women for the
day recently I but and also as a gun
enthusiast and someone who is a big
Second Amendment supporter i I've known
this for a while it's just like the
media is finally catching up with the
actual statistics is like oh whoa black
women actually think it's important to
protect themselves because a lot of them
are independent a lot of them are not
you don't have a spouse or a father
figure in the home I've got in trouble
for saying that by the way but I
actually grew up without a father and at
home so I also feel like I could say
that how dare you you racist
how dare you who grew in the situation
that the statistics bear out tell white
liberals something that they know
nothing about have that's outrageous we
have to edit that okay know that for a
mom they probably know that that well
that is that is really interesting these
the numbers do bear this out black women
in America are much more likely to be
victims of domestic violence why do you
think though right now
now the race and sex argument for gun
ownership is is it just that the
mainstream media is cracking people like
you are vocal and strong advocates for
sensible gun policy is that what's doing
it or is some other force going on
no it's Oh Trump is elected ah I know
that this statistic has been happening
for like what last five years we'll just
talk about it as if it happened the last
seven eight months right because then
Trump is racist and that helps our whole
narrative so yeah absolutely that's the
whole reason is because Trump is
president and they really don't like the
fact that black people are going to guns
I mean that's not part of that today
they live it so yeah of course they're
gonna talk about that now and that's
what they're going to use forth and as
the rights of orange Americans have come
to the fore in the Trump era of course
these other racial and gender is Allah
so come up as well Jacob you're from
that gun-toting freedom-loving
wonderland of Texas what is the best
argument against gun control there are
these great arguments now for specific
demographics racial and gender
there's the constitutional argument
self-defense so on and so forth what
arguments are going to work and what are
going to let me keep more of my guns in
this awful State of California I think
we should we should start by calling out
their their false comparison so for
instance the the Center for Disease
Control for which is for some reason
doing Studies on guns I don't know why
but they say oh well there's Alaska has
the second highest rate of suicides and
Alaska is number one in gun ownership oh
that must be the problem so if we
Institute gun control people will stop
offing themselves no that's not the case
that's a pretty cold and lonely place up
there yeah exactly so I think if we
break down how foolish their argument
sound Japan is has one of the highest
suicide rates in the world
guess what gun control so I think that
no matter no matter where they come at
you with you just got to break down
there they're fake studies they're fake
comparisons that's what it that's what
it boils down to is just ripping up
their arguments
I mean you are certainly the most
Napolitan and worldly of us your from
justin trudeau land you're currently
over in Asia why do Americans love guns
so much why do we love guns more than
everyone else in the world is there some
weird pathology about us or is it
because we love freedom well I think
it's exactly about like you said loving
freedom um you look at the history of
the United States and the fact that
there were Wars where you had to fight
off tyrannical government I don't think
it's any mystery why US has this
pro-second amendment culture and you
know regarding the fact that a lot of a
lot of the people who kind of go after a
Second Amendment
activists how they claim to be famous uh
and Tony I just saw on your Twitter feed
before the show that you have you know
hashtag empowerment and I think that's
actually a great message you know that
gun rights advocates can talk about is
that you know there's that saying that
God made men equal them sorry God
created man Sam Colt made them eagle
right and I think you know if you are a
woman if you are for women's empowerment
and equality I can't think of no better
equalizer than a gun frankly you know
and I say this I was like 110 pound
woman who is fully aware that no amount
of Krav Maga would ever make me any sort
of a match for someone like the rock
right and I think that you know people
who point to places like Canada and say
like oh look but it's so safe because
they have no guns actually you know on
average the average Canadian gun owner
owns more guns than the amiran owner so
just finding words I won't stand for
that kind of Pro kanata anti-american
rhetoric on my show yeah your ego
emotional gotta step up your gun
ownership and you know what are you not
going to do it we're talking eight or
nine right I mean Yemen's kicking
kicking your trash in that area but I
think I think it's part of what makes
Americans so free and the idea that you
know you have the right to protect
yourself you have the right to you know
if it needs be protect your
constitutional rights I think that is
intrinsic to American culture in
American history
yeah Antonia when when white liberals
are educating you about the experience
of black women in America how do they
resolve the cognitive dissonance of on
the one hand say
that cops are a racist bastion of white
supremacy and we should demilitarize
them and on the other hand only cops
should have the guns and be condemned by
the black people shouldn't have guns to
protect themselves how do they resolve
that they don't because we don't
understand the fallacy of our own
argument and I'm just like Oh mom yeah
all right thank you very much and then I
use the word mansplaining they stop
immediately I leave it's all gone
no we don't understand the fact that you
know now you see a leftist do so I could
understand where they're coming from and
their language and what they're trying
to do and I always bring it back to like
oh well don't you and I'm like talking
to a man right and I'm like but don't
you think you know as a feminist I have
a feminist don't you think that you
should you know have be able to enable a
woman to go with protect themselves
because they're independent and they
should have that that right to it it's a
woman's right don't you think so in and
they're like oh okay buzz words that I
usually don't know what to say unless I
have talking points
all right um well you're back I'm gonna
I'm going to step away and let you I'm
going to say that you actually know
you're talking about and then go postal
media and like you know see how subtweet
you so basically that works and Antonia
you that you used to be a leftist what
turns you into this gun-toting you're
sitting in a range while you do the
interview right winger what was
motivation well first of all I'm in
Texas so a little deranged you get to
choose but yeah definitely I definitely
I mean it just comes to the fact that
you know actually the gun right issues
what brought me more away from the left
realizing that yes about freedom I think
we do have this intrinsic you know you
know feeling it or this desire
I've Americans to make sure that we
protect that freedom some does people
need more time to get to the point that
yes done for a lot of people
particularly for women especially on
college campuses and that's why I'm on
campus carry activist means freedom it
means the freedom to have space in my
own hands either will to be empowered
not be a victim like the left really
like so much weight for women and for
black people and for a minority since
period absolutely the last best hope of
man on earth requires an armed and
dangerous citizenry I agree
so now Sonia I'd like really
Roger ever are there ever liberals who
just tell you why don't you just call
the cops but kind of fail to like
realize that according to their own
narrative those cops will unjustly
target you because of your race like
that you get you might be like there's
so many cognitive dissonance Rahming
Antoni has already told you she's not a
black woman because she's a pro-life
Republican she'll be fine with the [ __ ]
don't worry it's funny I always get that
so I wrote a piece for New York Times
that went out like a week or two ago so
most of them are white liberals okay so
most of their argument was oh I want to
be around her if she's shooting for
those like okay when are a certified
brain safety officer but things and then
still and then also like oh well you can
just call the cops or the campus police
and then you have like black liberals
who will attack me
no the most issues and they'll be like
well you know as a black woman or the
black person that you're you're you're
going to be more sought after from
police because you have a gun and
there's no open carry concealed carry
it's not for us as black people and I
just want to be one day I just let's put
them in a room together and like have
them you know talk pink would those two
points and then just be like there you
go you guys are both the problem Last
Man Standing wins yeah so yeah I doesn't
make any sense but one day I'll figure
out how to like you know bring out
together maybe a little clown next year
who knows maybe I'll be invited I'll
okay that's it now we need to discuss
the most important issue our day
forget health care forget the economy
forget Isis we need to know how to tell
if your child is transgender how is your
job there is a big piece that came out
over the weekend in with gender experts
so called gender experts I believe it
was in USA Today they said how can a
parent know if their child is
transgender
what separates a young boy who might be
transgender from one with a vivid
imagination who likes to dress up in his
sister's dresses what do you do if your
daughter tells you she is a boy you
correct her now
my priest Jorge rattler actually brought
this up in a column over the weekend
gender is a grammatical term it's a
point of grammar it's not a point of
biology like in French for instance pen
the word for pen is masculine the word
for pencil is feminine but pens aren't
men and pencils aren't women now actual
gender dysphoria and intersectionality
affect a vanishingly small minority of
the population for everyone else this
has just become a social justice warrior
point of discussion that only exists on
blogs basically roaming is this child
abuse to force these confusing modern
ideas of gender onto children I
absolutely think this is child abuse and
I've addressed this before on social
media and I've had people you know say
that I'm being bigoted racist somehow
also usually factors ringing but you
know just being prejudiced in general
and as someone who hopes to become a mom
and you know next five years I'm
anything to do with children childhood
development I care a lot about and if
you actually look at the fact that
childhood psychologists deliver 9 out of
10 children 90% of children who report a
feeling gender dysphoria during
childhood or adolescence as adults do
not end up transitioning right so that
means that if you are actually
transitioning your child based on their
reports of not feeling like the right
gender you know giving them things like
hormone blockers there's a 90% chance
that child will regret that decision
right just based on what we've seen so
far
your mutilation you're really changing
their body absolutely cause of sterility
right these hormone blockers that
prevent puberty combined with you know
let's say surgery at the time they turn
18 you are sterilizing them I think if
we're a society the degrees hey children
can't consent to things like intercourse
they can't they're not responsible
enough to do things like join the
military or Drive there is no way we can
say that there you know of a sound mind
to make a decision like transitioning
their gender and I think what is also
really interesting is that you know I
eiseley believe that transgenderism and
gender dysphoria you know it's a little
edge it a bit psychological issue
definitely seek treatment if you need it
but they've also done Studies on what
kind of factors might influence things
why
reporting gender dysphoria at an early
age but not transitioning and you know
it comes from a lot of the times issues
in the home related to their parents and
you know the in the environment that
they are raised in and how they view
gender you know things like male figures
not being present and stuff like that
like there are actually studies about
this that talk about this and you know
the the idea that we have now or anytime
someone you know might a girl might look
like kind of a tomboy boom transgender
oh my son likes pink instead of blue
boom transgenic ballet classes I'll
admit to it I was a little actor boy I
can what can I say I turn to the father
of a grandson you understand this now
but seriously if anything those kind of
ideas those reinforce gender norms which
I thought these progressives were
supposed to be about dismantling
absolutely absolutely right and this
brings up a hard point for conservatives
because we want to be nice guys we want
to be compassionate obviously these
people are suffering from a serious
condition that is really hard and
apparently there's not much of a cure
for it right now but Antonia can
conservatives embrace the logic of
transgenderism can we get on board with
it or does the the argument for
transgenderism and the transgender
movement fly in the face of conservatism
itself well I think you know that's what
the whole LGBT you whatever what's up in
such elemental I yeah I'm hungry I think
I mean it's a study show especially with
conservative Millennials that they are
more accepting of you know the gay
lifestyle right versus 10-15 years ago
what it would just been like no way most
people are just sucking of it now
regardless of what ideology you have so
you know and I think that's that's the
next thing they're trying to push and
that's where they're going in pools and
stuff like that because they want to
normalize it so 10-15 years from now our
kids we have kids are thinking it's a
normal thing that's exactly right
the lumping in tea with the LGBT has
made it part of this movement for sexual
freedom but it seems to me there's a big
difference between being sexually
attracted to the same gender or the same
sex rather supporting various sexual
acts and living arrangements and denying
basic biology and denying the innate sex
of human beings can we I think it's
probably easy enough for the right to
get on board with certain aspects of
that movement but can we get on board
with actually changing your sex
exactly I being wall made for example
when I became run-outs on the left it
left it sort of more on the right side I
actually talked a lot more gay
conservative like I knew about gay
conservatives and I knew about anybody
else who wasn't you know Bo Tong quote
not to be conservative first so I went
to Yale so we only had gay conservatives
we only basically had gay people in
general that one in for maybe more but
yeah most of course I think a lot of the
people now in the conservative movement
there are plenty of a lot Cabin
Republicans who do a great job in
activism exactly yes and so I definitely
don't think that's the issue another
thing I noticed too is that now they're
trying to put you know rape into the
whole thing like with black lives matter
they put the whole you know queer
transgender uh narrative into that as
well as part of their agenda but now
they put that I think the flag now has
the rainbow flag I have a brown stripe I
think they just bring the whole thing as
like oh yeah God's people and prompt you
for your part of this movement too and
then if you are talking to actual black
and brown people they're like I know or
not because they're super conservative
when it comes up it's like you're not on
making intersectionality in that like
you you have to increase your
intersectionalities because you're a
white male it's ya know knew that black
and brown was a sexual preference I
suppose when you think of Antonia Okafor
then you certainly could understand the
logic but in general I don't see how
they came to that conclusion well no I
mean that's just part of the whole thing
and that's why I'm more vocal because I
know that as a black woman they really
don't like that I'm like messing up
their narratives because that respect
for servos later on so they kind of like
sticks to other black liberals on me and
then I'm just like dude do you even
agree with this like hell no but I felt
like you know I'm like okay fine except
fair enough that's a fair argument now
Jacob you know our friend Ben Shapiro he
has the number one rated conservative
podcast in the country it's number one
but my podcast identifies as the number
not only the number one conservative
podcast in the country the number one
podcast in the country should I get a
raise yeah
we lost Jacob I hope we muted him
because he was disagreeing with that
obvious premise what I could answer
Jacob do we have you back they can't
hear me yes okay no yeah absolutely and
this whole thing of where people say oh
I I identify as this or identify as this
I can say I can identify as whatever I
want to apparently and that and that's
alright you know I may be yeah for sure
I mean I live in California but I
identify as a Texan because I was born
there but you know it's you know
speaking of which I'd love to know what
the last flavor of Blue Bell ice cream
Antonia had I'm craving Blue Bell ice
cream you can't find it out here in this
desert
but uh anyway yeah I think the soul
we're identifying one thing it just
breaks down when it comes to logic you
can't you can't say oh I'm this and then
just magically it happens that that's
just not that's that in itself is not
logical right I can't allow this bigotry
to go on anymore panel it has been great
to have you
Antonio can for roaming millennial and
Jacob arey get out of here now we'll see
you again later now it's time for final
thoughts
[Music]
speaking of propaganda here is some of
my own many on the right are reluctant
to associate too closely with the
president because they consider him
crass uncouth below the dignity of their
rarefied social circles forget about
deregulation of the federal agencies
originalist jurists to preserve our
imperiled first and second Amendment
rights most importantly our right to
self-government forget a return to
sensible national policy both foreign
and domestic hammer of the court
intrigue mock the bubbly blondes on
Facebook they insist but as Ronald
Reagan noted the person who agrees with
you 80% of the time is a friend and an
ally not a 20% traitor rather than
attack the president over tactics and
then attack him again for changing
tactics it seems far more adult and
useful to hold the snark and support the
only team presently capable of achieving
our actual political goals in a phrase
despite the constant negative press
coffe FA
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
nul show we'll be back
and tomorrow join us we'll do it again
[Music]
[Music]